Steve the left side front Olaf remark
hey Steve mark Medina bury a newsgroup
it look like there are a lot of times
throughout the game you guys are playing
in mud what do you think contributed to
that overall it playing in mud - playing
in mud yeah what do you think
contributes just overall execution well
their defense was great and you know
wasn't our best night but we just got
outplayed so simple as that move on to
the next one and how's how's Andre doing
I think he's doing okay but well we'll
have an update tomorrow the next
question to John in the front row on the
right John Dickinson 95 7 the game what
in particular made siakam and Gasol so
effective against you guys tonight
well siakam was brilliant I mean he was
hitting shots from everywhere he hit
four threes you know he he'd been
struggling from the three-point line in
the last couple series so he got he got
Tackett to go and and I think actually
I'm wrong on that he had two threes but
Gasol we left a couple times early in
the game and didn't rotate you know we
we just gave him a couple of Dera shots
and and he knocked him down so you know
there's gonna there's gonna be some
openings those guys made their plays
made their shots you know biggest thing
for me was our transition defense was
just awful
and that's the game that's the number
one priority when you play Toronto you
have to have to take care of their
transition and we gave up 24 fast-break
points we turn it over 17 times so
that's the game really the other stuff
you know guys are gonna make shots
missed shots are gonna have good games
they're gonna have bad games but it's
kind of the you know the key points that
you can take care of that that are the
most important and we didn't take care
of that not transition last row on the
right side Timms Steve Tim Reynolds with
the AP I know you guys have been through
long breaks before and with all credit
to the Raptors
defense of course did you feel like rust
was in any way a factor for you guys
tonight not playing for a week and a
half it doesn't matter one way or the
other you know so if we had won the the
the story would have been that we were
well rested so though we lost so we were
rusty so it doesn't matter Anthony go
ahead right side Anthony Snyder with the
earth what do you think of DeMarcus and
his first game back and is there a
possibility you you're thinking about
maybe increasing his playing time
waiting for I thought DeMarcus did a
really nice job made some great passes
we could run some offense through him
you know it's so early in the process
for him
he played eight minutes and I thought
his minutes were good but it's a huge
adjustment to play after a six week
seven week absence especially at this
level in the NBA Finals against a team
that that's pretty fast already so I
thought he did really well and we'll
look at the tape and we'll see what what
we decide to do with his role going
forward left side Jim Kelly Steve Jim
cow call me the athletic over here
you've played against these guys you
know how long and athletic they are but
was it a little bit of a shock to the
system you think for your guys offense
elite to play against that kind of
length and do you think maybe you've
figured some things out or found some
more space as the game went on well I
think that you know the biggest thing
coming in is we really didn't feel like
we knew this team very well you know we
we've obviously we only play them two
times a year and this year's team is
different with Kawhi and been the two
meetings that we had with them a lot of
guys were were missing including Kawhi
in Oakland he didn't play and then I
think Steph missed the game up here
other guys were missing so it's it's
going to be really good for us to have a
game on tape where we can really pick it
apart and see what we can do better I
thought we made made a good effort in
the second half got back in the game our
guys did some good things but made too
many mistakes
to to actually go ahead and win the game
left side second row Steve radio coach
Michael Pina SP nation kind of jumping
off that question what problems does to
run those defense pose that you haven't
seen in this postseason run and even in
the last four finals runs that you've
been on I don't know that I can sit here
and compare them to you know at every
playoff team we've played but they're
very long and athletic they're tough
they get after you and you know they
play well together they got a lot of
versatility I think they're they're
actually a lot like our team you know
they can switch and guard different
positions and that sort of thing and so
I thought they did a really good job
they made some big shots you know Danny
Green's three at the end of the half
contested right in front of their bench
was a big one
Sayaka made a three out top right down
the stretch so the game went from I
think two or four to ten at the end of
the half and then they made a couple
other big ones in the second half so
give them credit I thought they played a
great game they deserve to win and we
got to play better if we're gonna if
we're gonna beat him left side in the
back on the side Steve Ryan Gorski San
Francisco Examiner early on when they
were kind of they were not giving Klay
any open looks and they were really sort
of making life difficult for Steph how
much does say a Kevin Durant floater or
a Kevin Durant spot up jumper changed
that offensive dynamic at that point for
you guys again I'll go back to my
earlier answer doesn't matter until he's
out there so if he's if he's out there
he's pretty good so but if he's not out
there we play we play with the guys we
have and we've got enough we've we've
we've won the last whatever six games
without in five six games so we have
enough but you play with the guys who
are healthy and you go so we'll see what
happens
final question right side in the back
Dan
dan Devine the ringer to that point
about having enough you went I think 11
or 12 D pretty early in the game but
some of those lineups in the second the
beginning a second quarter beginning a
fourth quarter kind of fits and starts
II maybe because of de Marcus coming
back what did you see out of your depth
today do you feel confident that this is
another series where you can and will
need to play a lot of guys our bench was
great you know
Jonas hit a couple threes Quinn cook
came in did a nice job and you know the
way we've played our bench we've since
Kevin and DeMarcus have been out we play
a lot of guys but they don't play big
minutes so we're trying to find
combinations we're trying to find guys
who can step out on the floor for a few
minutes make a shot make a play and I
thought the the bench did a fantastic
job tonight they were really good they
kept us in the game but again give
credit to Toronto they they played a
great game they made a lot of shots
difficult shots and our transition
defense and turnovers that stuff it's
really hard to overcome especially on
the road so we got to get better with
that thanks everybody thank you Steve